Nicaragua is building a massive canal
that will split the country in two and
uproot thousands of people the Chinese
led firm is running the project the
government hopes the canal will bring
tens of thousands of jobs and help lift
nicaragua out of poverty but anti canal
activists accuse the government of
selling out and they're getting
organized
we traveled with activist Dennis
Castillo de Brito the coastal town where
the canal will meet the Pacific Ocean
the canal esta parte like a Pentagon
Cooper at Apache all this bitch called
the Johanna konta
Fernando a Lakota Selena it's beautiful
yes indeed I'm invisible fiamma grande
que Gigante da costa grande que get the
pole is it totem an eclectic Austin the
proposed canal would cross the
freshwater lake nicaragua and stretch
more than 170 miles to the caribbean
coast displacing more than a hundred
thousand people it would be wider deeper
than more than three times longer than
the Panama Canal the President Daniel
Ortega has given the Chinese led firm HK
nd the rights to build the canal without
consulting the public Nicaragua's
Parliament approved the deal in just a
few days granting HK nd a 100 year
tax-free concession that includes the
right to expropriate lands at will
in late December 2014 hundreds of
farmers protested around the country
police responded with violent crackdown
yoga getting a set s enroll a la mayor
Fenty appropri I am abhi Tony Korea
Nicaragua Oh Tov your tiger is one of
the protest leaders targeted by
authorities la amenaza an sido cantante
amenaza de muerte a party s okay to a
hods detenido en manera legal qui salba
he mente golpeado me fracture Araneta
bras oh me me me aroun kulit a so en el
Ojo
this protest don't show any sign of
going away do you think things are going
to become more violent around the
country el campesino Nicaraguan say a
noventri r su propiedad de lo que
queremos Evatt ra you may order a
momento de sangre nicaragua y por eso
que nosotros
Kumiko a case a gobierno se siente ADEA
lugar con nosotros para él hace oh yo
sword o that night Octavio called a
meeting of activists to prepare for
their next
despite growing resistance in the canals
path the government insists the majority
of Nicaragua's six million people favor
the project so we're about 150
kilometers north of the capital Managua
this is a very poor area so we want to
find out how people feel will some of
the prosperity that politicians are
talking about affect them up here la
gente aquí que necesitan I mentioned
safety rope for some bucks okay but a
lot of teenagers ever come on TV it's a
holy relic welcome here and oscillate
okay all right Mucha gente sold acuerdo
del the canal three tangent well which I
ain't a para la patrulla de keep losing
gente camellia ya tengo tu sabe erotic
much like a lot but around Lake
Nicaragua the project is anything but
welcome when a Chinese census team
showed up in the hamlet of cruz Verde in
September 2014
farmers greeted them with machetes oh
god my feeling lucky salera
look someone late over here in a few
amory Largo
regress on aqui no yaki know the
entrance aquí tienen me LM track a kiss
a socket when photo Susac
caramel apple Azealia camino al akhirin
log was we important telenovela la
villita villarica right Abuelita a
two-year investigation by Nicaragua's
leading environmental group concluded
the canal poses an extraordinary threat
to Lake Nicaragua it further warned that
there will not be enough water to
maintain the canal 25 years from now
today the Nicaraguan government has not
issued an environmental impact report of
its own this is the biggest challenge my
generation is going to face not just
from the environmental consequences the
canal clearly is going to have on our
main water resources on forests monica
lopez bell tadhana was a lawyer who's
fighting against the canal in court she
says there are 40 constitutional
violations in the Chinese concession but
it's not just the interest on e canal
it's a dry canal it's a pipeline it's to
the water ports it's an airport it's
free trade zones so the list keeps
growing the direct payment acara was
getting out of this it's 100 million
dollars for our 116 years concession 100
million dollars is the amount of money
that comes into our economy every two
months are migrating people in Spain in
aus in Costa Rica they send in two
months what the canal concession is
paying for 116 years so in which head
that it's a good deal telemarket ella
vera is the government spokesman for the
canal project the Chinese concession is
paying the government just ten million
dollars a year to operate the canal this
is small change
I've heard that remittances sent from
Nicaragua is living abroad or actually
more than this amount how is this
benefiting the people la cantidad KKK
sea neva pagará Nicaragua es muy pequeño
effective pero a parte de eso by pasando
an OLE o por ciento parano
de la inversión a patrimonio Nacional
para an era un presupuesto más Alto
unproductive inter no más Alto una
condición economic a sushi are para lo
Nicaragua say muy superior environmental
activist say despair
it will destroy the largest source of
fresh water lake nicaragua in Central
America to say nothing of all the tens
of thousands of people who will be
displaced by the canal project what do
you say to them
poor dick aragua Ellaria por la cual
baaaa a transit a los barkos en menos de
Lune Oh por ciento de la superficie de
la go pro Demonte ESO se reforest are
las cuentas no solamente las cuentas de
la escena los ríos yo a manohar
diferente las cuentas yellow graphic 'as
poor tanto damos el balance a Vassar
positivo a un impacto mental CeeLo AI yo
soy de niro a un impacto meet our sin
embargo el balon sell totales positi o
el ambiente vassar el gran cuñado quien
a van a ser lo Grande's Purdy doors lo
que quieran que Nicaragua say mantenga a
lapa brezza pero quiere queremos la paz
el Palacio del Rio vamos a ganar a in
the absence of transparency and with the
stakes so high it's difficult to say who
oh when NT canal activists refusing to
back down
que nosotros OB OB Luce porque soy el
contra del Progreso no estoy en contra
deli Justicia sls taco meat en este
pueblo y esta protesta nosotros vamos
hacer monteri endo honk a egg esta lucha
no scope no stoke a marido